while the pandemic is not over
we have now passed the peak of the
omicron wave with cases falling
hospitalizations in england now fewer
than 10 000
and still falling
and the link between infection and
severe disease substantially weakened
over 71 percent of all adults are now
boosted in england
including 93 percent of those age 70 and
over
and together with the treatments and
scientific understanding of the virus
that we've built up we now have
sufficient levels of immunity to
complete the transition from protecting
people with government interventions
to relying on vaccines and treatments as
our first line of defense
as we have throughout the past two years
we will continue to work closely with
the devolved administrations as they
decide how to take forward their own
plans and today's strategy shows how we
will structure our approach in england
around four principles
first
we will remove
all remaining
domestic restrictions in law
[Music]
from this thursday 24th of february we
will end the legal requirement to
self-isolate following a positive test
and so we will also end self-isolation
support payments although covered
provisions for statutory sick pay can
still be claimed for a further month
we will end routine contact tracing
and no longer ask fully vaccinated
closed contacts and those under 18 to
test daily for seven days
and we will remove the legal requirement
for close contacts who are not fully
vaccinated to self-isolate
until the 1st of april we will advise
people who test positive to stay at home
but after that we will encourage people
with covid19 symptoms
to exercise personal responsibility
just as we encourage people who may have
flu to be considerate
to others
mr speaker
it's only because
levels of immunity are so high and
deaths are now if anything below where
you would normally expect for this time
of year that we can lift these
restrictions
and it's only because we know omicron is
less severe
that testing for omicron on the colossal
scale we've been doing is much less
important and much less valuable in
preventing serious illness
we should be proud that the uk has
established the biggest testing program
per person
of any large country in the world
this came at vast cost the test trace
and isolation budget in 2020-2021
exceeded the entire budget of the home
office
it cost a further 15.7 billion pounds in
this financial year and 2 billion pounds
in january alone at the height of the
omicron wave
we must now scale this back
from today we're removing the guidance
for staff and students in most education
and child care settings to undertake
twice weekly asymptomatic taste testing
and from the first of april
where winter is over and the virus will
spread less easily
we will end free symptomatic and
asymptomatic testing for the general
public
we will continue to provide free
symptomatic tests to the oldest age
groups and those most vulnerable to
cobit and in line with the practice in
many other countries we're working with
retailers to ensure that everyone who
wants to can buy a test
from april the 1st we will also no
longer recommend the use of voluntary
covered status certification
although the nhs app will continue to
allow people to indicate their
vaccination status for international
travel
mr speaker the government will also
expire all temporary provisions
of the coronavirus act
of the original 40 20 have already
expired and 16 will expire on the 24th
of march
and the last four relating to
innovations in public service will
expire six months later after we have
made those improvements permanent via
other means
second we will continue to protect the
most vulnerable with targeted vaccines
and treatments
the uk government has procured enough
doses of vaccine to anticipate a wide
range of possible jcvi
recommendations
and today we're taking further action to
guard against a possible resurgence of
the virus
accepting jcvi jcvi advice for a new
spring booster offered to those aged 75
and older to older care home residents
and those over 12 who are
immunosuppressed
the uk is also
leading the way on antivirals and
therapeutics with our antivirals task
force securing a supply of almost five
million
more per head than any other country in
europe
third sage advised there is considerable
uncertainty about the future path of the
pandemic and there may of course be
significant resurgences they are certain
there will be new variants and it is
very possible they will be worse than
omicron
so we will maintain our resilience to
manage and respond to these risks
including our world leading ons survey
which will allow us to continue tracking
the virus in granular detail with
regional with regional and age
breakdowns helping us to spot surges as
and where they happen
and our laboratory networks will help us
understand the evolution of the virus
and identify any changes in
characteristics
we will prepare and maintain our
capabilities to ramp up testing
we will continue to support other
countries in developing their own
surveillance capabilities because a new
variant can emerge anywhere and we will
meet our commitment to donate 100
million vaccine doses by june as part of
our agreement at the uk's g7 summit to
provide a billion doses to vaccinate the
world over the next year
in all circumstances
our aim will be to manage and respond to
future risks
through more routine public health
interventions with pharmaceutical
interventions as the first line of
defense
fourth we will build on the innovation
that has defined the best of our
response to the pandemic
the vaccines task force will continue to
ensure that the uk has access to
effective vaccines as they become
available already securing contracts
with manufacturers trialling
bivalent vaccines which would provide
protection against covid variants
the therapeutics task force will
continue to support seven national
priority clinical trial platforms
focused on prevention novel treatments
and treatments for long coping
we are refreshing our biosecurity
strategy to protect the uk against
natural zoonosis
and accidental laboratory leaks
as well as the potential for biological
threats emanating from state and
non-state actors
and building on the five-point plan i
set out at the un and the agreements
reached at the uk's g7 last year we are
working with our international partners
on future pandemic preparedness
including through a new pandemic treaty
an effective early warning system or
global pandemic radar and a mission to
make safe and effective diagnostics
therapeutics and vaccines available
within the first 100 days of a future
pandemic threat being island identified
and we will be hosting a global pandemic
preparedness summit next month
mr speaker
kovid will not suddenly disappear
so those who would wait for a total end
to this war before lifting the remaining
regulations
would be restricting the liberties of
the british people for a long time to
come
this government does not believe that
that is right or necessary
restrictions pose a heavy toll on our
economy
our society our mental well-being and on
the life chances of our children and we
do not need to pay that cost any longer
we have a population that is protected
by the biggest vaccination program in
our history we have the antivirals the
treatments and the scientific
understanding of this virus and we have
the capabilities to respond rapidly to
any resurgence or new variant and mr
speaker it is time that we got our
confidence back we don't need laws to
compel people to be considerate to
others we can rely on that sense of
responsibility towards one another
providing practical advice in the
knowledge that people will follow it to
avoid infecting loved ones and others
so let us learn
to live with this virus
and continue protecting ourselves and
others without restricting our freedoms
and in that spirit mr speaker i commend
this statement to the house